I'd like to talk to you about solving
these kinematics problems so we're going
to actually start by asking ourselves
three separate questions anytime we
start one of these kinematics problems
and this will help us really figure out
what's happening in the motion so the
first question that we want to ask our
is how many objects are moving so do we
care about more than one object and if
we do we need to make sure to label each
one distinctively we also want to know
how many dimensions we need to care
about for each object the second
question that we want to ask ourselves
is how many stages of motion does each
object have so for an example for
example if you're told that a bicycle is
initially accelerating and then at a
certain time it stops accelerating then
you know that that initial acceleration
is going to have different equations of
motion than the point in time where it
now has an acceleration equal to zero
the final thing that we want to think
about we want to figure out what special
conditions there are so for example you
might be told that the cart is initially
at rest so what does that mean in
reality it means that you can write down
something like V of zero is equal to
zero that's what it means for the cart
to initially be at rest the cart is V at
time zero is equal to zero so those are
the kinds of special conditions that you
need to pay attention for in the problem
and that will help you figure out get
all the the numbers or the variables
that you need to solve your equation
once you're done thinking through these
different steps the final thing you
should always do before starting a
problem is draw out your problem
properly label your system and then of
course draw your origin your axes and
your unit vectors and this way it'll be
easy for you to organize all of the
different information that you have